[Music]
most americans are aware of the roles
that rosa parks martin luther king jr
bus boycotts and school desegregation
played in the american civil rights
movement not as well known are the
effects of the constitution's commerce
clause and partisan politics
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives we'll hear
from four experts on government history
and constitutional law as they explain
some lesser-known moments that shape the
civil rights movement in the united
states
we start now by looking at the period
after the american civil war that led to
the call for civil rights in america
[Music]
during the era of jim crow in the
american south which lasts from the late
1870s until the mid-1960s
americans experienced extreme
discrimination and considerable violence
in this roughly 80-year period the
injustices and inequalities of everyday
life for african-americans in the south
was brutal
with lynchings a common occurrence
a critical juncture occurred in 1896
when the supreme court decided the
famous case of plessy versus ferguson
in this case the supreme court ruled
that separate railway cars for whites
and blacks was permissible
as long as the cars were equal in
facilities
citing this separate but equal clause
states and cities instituted laws that
prevented direct contact between blacks
and whites
segregating lunch counters bus station
waiting rooms drinking fountains and
even bathrooms
these segregation laws and efforts to
promote racial discrimination were
largely aimed at dehumanizing african
americans
so even though slavery had officially
ended
african americans were prevented from
owning property escaping poverty
attaining education and training and
participating as equal citizens in
american democracy
the ruling of plessy versus ferguson
ensured the survival of jim crow laws
for over a half century
we credit the american civil rights
movement as helping to significantly
expand democracy and civil rights in
america
the movement is a profound example of a
successful social movement that aimed to
change laws and attitudes for the direct
benefit of african americans and the
collective benefit of all americans
in 1954 the supreme court decided the
famous case of brown versus board of
education of topeka kansas
overturning the precedent of separate
but equal that was set in the plessy
case some 60 years earlier
in brown vs board chief justice earl
warren wrote the opinion of the court
calling for an end to legalized racial
segregation in public schools
this was a huge victory for the civil
rights cause
but the decision led also to massive
backlash
u.s senate and house members from the
south
vowed to prevent enforcement with new
legislation
and membership in the racist ku klux
klan organization spiked
against this backdrop a new boycott
began
on december 1st 1955
rosa parks was taking the bus home from
her job as a department store seamstress
in montgomery alabama when a white man
boarded and the bus driver ordered her
to give up her seat
rosa parks and her husband had served in
various roles at the local chapter of
the naacp and had investigated sexual
assault cases during the 1940s
now
she refused to relinquish her seat on
the full bus
she was arrested and taken into custody
outraging the local black community
african-american leaders including a
young minister new to town by the name
of martin luther king jr
gathered in the mount zion church to
coordinate a response
they decided to boycott city buses on
the day of rosa parks's trial on
december 5th 1955.
the campaign drew such overwhelming
support
that black leaders extended the boycott
for
381 days
dr king argued that it was an effective
method of passive resistance he said
christ showed us the way
and gandhi in india showed it could work
president john f kennedy moved
cautiously on civil rights during the
first two years of his administration
but in 1963 he committed to the cause
kennedy said the events in birmingham
have so increased the cries for equality
that they can no longer be ignored
in a televised address that june he said
this nation
for all its hopes and all its boast
will not be fully free
until all its citizens are free
and he said he would send civil rights
legislation to congress
banning racial segregation
throughout the country
at the time
activists had been planning a massive
protest march in washington
now it would be in support of the
proposed civil rights law
on august 28 1963
some 250 000 people
took part in the march
and martin luther king delivered his
famous i have a dream speech
100 years after abraham lincoln's famous
emancipation proclamation
african americans still weren't free
king said
instead
they lived as exiles in their own land
as president kennedy's civil rights
legislation made its way to congress
it might have appeared that the civil
rights movement had reached a turning
point
but in birmingham
segregationists bombed the city's 16th
street baptist church on september
15th four young girls
getting ready for the service
died in the blast
two months later
kennedy himself was assassinated
vice president lyndon johnson assumed
the highest office in the land
and publicly committed to seeing
kennedy's civil rights legislation
through
but the problem of segregation is
relevant to our continuing exploration
of the commerce clause because the
court's rulings in brown and other
important equal protection cases
actually changed little for african
americans on the ground for many years
it was to address this situation that a
full decade after brown congress passed
the civil rights act of 1964
and it was the commerce clause that the
government used to justify many parts of
that statute
you may well ask why
a statute about civil rights certainly
seems like it has more to do with
concepts like equal protection and basic
fairness than with the sort of economic
matters that would seem to be at the
core of the commerce clause
a more plausible constitutional
provision to justify the civil rights
act might therefore be section 5 of the
14th amendment which empowers congress
to pass laws enforcing the substantive
provisions of the 14th amendment
including the equal protection clause
when congress sees violations of the
14th amendment it can legislate under
section 5 to try to prevent or remedy
those violations
the problem with using section 5 to
support the civil rights act however was
that some important 19th century
precedent had construed that section
narrowly
specifically in an 1883 case called the
civil rights cases the court had held
that congress can only legislate under
section 5 to address governmental
violations of rights
but segregation was not just a product
of governmental decision
to be sure there was state-sponsored
segregation and congress pretty clearly
could use section 5 to pass a law
addressing that
but many private white businesses also
practice segregation denying african
americans a wide range of services
at businesses such as restaurants
theaters and hotels
many provisions of the civil rights act
of 1964 dealt with this private racism
and exclusion
the civil rights act signed into law in
july of 1964
prohibited discrimination in public
places
made employment discrimination illegal
and provided for the integration of
schools and other public facilities
it was the most significant civil rights
legislation since the civil war era
unlike revolutionaries in other
historical contexts
civil rights activists didn't pick up
arms or man barricades
instead they joined arms sang hymns such
as we shall overcome
and use their bodies and courage to
assert the rights of all people
and the justice of their cause
a segregationist attacked with billy
clubs nooses
guns and bombs
civil rights revolutionaries
wielded what dr king called
the weapon of love
this
in and of itself was revolutionary
on august 6th 1965
congress enacted another piece of
significant civil rights legislation the
voting rights act
it stipulated that no state or local
government could deny american citizens
the right to vote on the basis of race
in the months after passage
250 000 new black voters registered to
exercise rights originally granted to
them in the 15th amendment
it was in the fifth party system that
democratic candidate for president john
f kennedy calculated that if democrats
embraced the enfranchisement of african
americans in the south
the party could expand its coalition in
a way that would provide an advantage to
northern liberals such as kennedy
it's important to remember that during
this time
ideology and political party were not as
aligned as they are today
the democratic coalition was made up of
northerners and conservative southerners
and the republican coalition was made up
of conservative northerners
in retrospect it seems like the
republican party could have moved first
to enfranchise african americans and
expanded their voting coalition in the
south but the democrats beat them to it
it was under a democratic president that
the civil rights act and voting rights
act were passed in 1964 and 1965
setting up a virtual marriage of
political loyalty between democrats and
african americans that still persists
today
but passage of the 1965 voting rights
act
and the martyrdom of martin luther king
jr in 1968 did not secure
racial justice in this country
on the contrary the escalating mass
incarceration of black men in our
nation's prisons over the last 50 years
now exists
as a vehicle of social control
on a scale that actually exceeds that of
19th century slavery
more black men are currently under
custodial control
in prisons on probation or on parole
than were held as slaves in 1850
at the height of the plantation system
all of this is recent history the result
of a backlash against advances made by
african americans during the civil
rights movement
beginning with barry goldwater's tough
on crime presidential campaign in 1964
and the shift to focusing on street
crime and drug law enforcement that
accompanied president reagan's election
america's half-century-old war on drugs
has swept more and more black people
into prison
incarcerating them for petty drug
offences
for which they were and still sometimes
are disproportionately punished when
compared to white defendants committing
similar crimes
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here